un salon funéraire aurait-il tenté de
profiter de la pandémie pour demander
plus cher robert pichette vient de
mourir de l'aco vide son frère paul et
sa conjointe qui s'occupe des
arrangements funéraires ont eu toute une
surprise en recevant une facture
additionnelle du salon alors que tout
était payé depuis longtemps selon le
contrat de prêt arrangements funéraires
le défunt devait être incinérée dans un
cercueil en carton
ce qui se fait couramment dans les codes
d'incinération mais le salon funéraire à
contacter monsieur pichette pour lui
expliquer qu'une exigence de la santé
publique les oublis j'ai maintenant à
utiliser des cercueils en bois pour
toutes les dépouilles affectés par la
coved 19
parce que les cercueils en bois sont
plus étanches et le salon lui réclamer
un supplément de 200 dollars or c'est
faux
québec nous oblige pas les pompes
funèbres a utilisé des cercueils de bois
pour l'incinération décor cosy de 19 et
six recueils de cartons sont aussi
permis d'ailleurs la loi est claire
un salon funéraire ne peut pas demander
plus que ce qui est prévu au contrat
sauf si ces frais sont dus à une
exigence d autorité sanitaire ce qui
n'est clairement pas le kop ici
finalement l'entreprise funéraire a fini
par reconnaître son erreur et a
remboursé que la famille du défunt
donc tout est bien qui finit bien par
ailleurs j'en profite pour vous rappeler
qu'un service qui n'a pas été rendu à
cause de la pandémie n'a pas à être
facturés et ça ça s'applique aussi au
salon funéraire
je vous dis ça parce que si la dépouille
a été affectée par la coved
il est interdit de l'embaumer ou de lui
faire une toilette funéraire alors si
ces services ont été facturés dans le
cadre par exemple d'un préarrangements
funéraires l'entreprise funéraire doit
rembourser ces sommes sans aucune
pénalité pour plus de détails consultez
le site internet de la facture